- It's fun, challenging, and
sometimes a bit stressful
because I might have
forgotten a negative sign
or a certain decimal,
and that gets me wrong.
And once I find what my mistake
was I'm literally relieved
because I learned something new
and I know to not forget that again.
It really felt like I was
trying my best on something
and then all of a sudden
it just didn't really work
because I missed one little thing.
So I had to practice again
and then get it all right.
- It really makes me feel like
even when you make mistakes
you learn from those mistakes,
and that kinda really
benefits you, I think,
more than actually
getting the right answer
'cause you know, like you
said you said with Sophia,
you get that extra missing puzzle piece.